well Yemen after five months looks like
Syria after five years that's how the
head of the International Red Cross
described Yemen after a recent visit
nearly four thousand people have been
killed since a coalition led by Saudi
Arabia and backed by the United States
started bombing Yemen on March 25th half
the dead are civilians hundreds are only
children in all over one and a half
million Yemenis have fled their homes
the Coalition wants to kick out the
Houthis an armed movement from the
country's north that took over the
capital in much of the country last year
the Houthis they say they're fighting a
central authority that backed by Saudi
Arabia and his allies has historically
persecuted them and both sides have been
accused of putting civilian lives at
risk
airstrikes have killed hundreds of
civilians and human rights groups say
the Saudi coalition has targeted densely
populated areas they've also accused
both the Houthis and pro-government
forces of routinely attacking populated
areas with imprecise heavy weapons Yemen
is the poorest country in the Arab world
with weak infrastructure and an
impoverished population even before the
war 60% of Yemenis needed food and
emergency relief now with a fighting
blocking access to food and major ports
destroyed that number has reached 80%
and a recent coalition airstrike on the
hood data port a key hub for getting
food into northern Yemen is likely to
make things worse things are so bad now
that the World Food Program is saying
that Yemen is just one step away from
famine and children are the worst
affected 1.8 million kids will suffer
from malnutrition if the fighting
continues and their futures are also
under threat more than 400 schools have
been damaged or destroyed and hundreds
of others have been occupied either by
armed groups or families fleeing the
fighting thousands of schools remain
shut leaving two to three million Yemeni
kids without an education and now
the Coalition says it will keep fighting
until it recaptures the capital sana one
of the oldest cities in the world a lot
of Stella's heritage has been destroyed
over the past five months
ahead of the coming assault residents
have been told to flee but fuel
shortages make that virtually impossible
for many so it looks like the
humanitarian crisis is only going to get
worse
[Music]